what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us is trying to get our big
i mean our lunch money right
i'm here we're in uniform we're ready to
rock and roll
it's a friday you know we got that
friday energy that trillionaire energy
let's go block five is now sponsoring
lunch money go get a block by account
block fight.com
they're awesome you'll be awesome if you
have a block by account if you don't
have a block by account you're not
awesome so go be awesome and get a
blackfy account
you can buy and sell crypto you can earn
up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account and
you can get a us dollar loan against
your bitcoin collateral go check it out
blockbuy.com
oh let's go okay so i was just you know
smiling at the people
um goldman sachs says that
says that bitcoin's meteoric rise is
tracking a key proxy for global growth
including so um
this analyst at goldman sachs said both
institutional investors and wealthy
individuals avoid cryptocurrency due to
its inherent transparency issues
while speculative retail investment
causes
bitcoin to act as an excessive risky
asset
but copper and gold are rising as a
result
bitcoin's popping because bitcoins
popping you know why it's going up
it's because there's a limited supply
and demand is increasing so the question
is
why is demand increasing well maybe it's
because
these governments are absolutely
destroying the currency
so if you're sitting with a bunch of
money in a bank account right now it's
getting less and less valuable because
the purchasing power is going away
well if they would stop doing that then
people wouldn't have to go look for an
alternative but because they won't stop
doing it and they're actually going to
accelerate doing it
then that means people are going to go
look for an alternative and that
alternative is bitcoin the greatest
store of wealth
that the world's ever seen if you look
and see what's happened over the last 10
years
i have a question yes okay thank you um
who the hell is investing in copper
copper farmers no like she doesn't even
know that copper farmers don't exist but
go ahead
copper is a metal they use no i know
what a conference
i thought it was kind of like the miners
it's not really you can't really
mine bitcoin yes you could but copper
who is investing in copper copper
investors why
are people who need it or people who
need to buy it to use it
first fascinating all right next thing
um coinbase pop-pop ipo
is going public
uh file that's s1 and
it's the largest u.s cryptocurrency
exchange and it did it at an interesting
time when bitcoin hit 23k do you think
they waited
disclaimer do you think they waited
disclaimer what
i'm an investor through spvs so anything
i say here is my personal opinion has
nothing to do with anything else
but uh they claim that they have 35
million registered accounts they claim
to have over 25 billion dollars
in assets under custody uh this is a
pretty pretty pretty incredible
um business and my guess this is i don't
have the financials uh but my guess is
that they're doing somewhere between 500
million
and like three to five billion in
revenue somewhere in that range big
range 500
million to 5 billion uh but it wouldn't
surprise me if the ipo of the price is
somewhere in the 20 to 30 billion dollar
range which would be
wild but do we think that they waited
for bitcoin to pop and be like let's go
oh they definitely there's definitely
value
to doing it when bitcoin is at an
all-time high
i mean they might have waited literally
for it to hit an all-time high who knows
electric vehicle maker tesla is poised
to enter the s
p 500 and what will be the largest
rebalancing in the history of that
index the trading volume is expected to
be so heavy that some are concerned it
could result in
fireworks at the close what the hell is
a firework
no fireworks like like chaos like oh
i thought it was like a financial term
oh it is it's a scientific term
but anyway so tesla is about to be
popping
people the traders are bracing for wild
action in historic volumes ahead of us
i have an announcement this is a
surprise
i have an announcement if you are under
the age of
14 or 15 and you're watching this show
today's a special day today
is national ice cream lunch money day
which means
that on ice cream day your parents have
to go buy you ice cream
so if you're under the age of 15 turn to
your parents right now and say
pomp said that we're supposed to get ice
cream today and then you can thank me
later
where did this come from if you're under
15.
your parents have to buy you ice cream
today it's a national law
it's a national law when you see them
all day long just keep saying
pom said you're supposed to buy me ice
cream yeah but it's december who's
eating ice cream in december it's cold
outside
me and all the kids under 15. oh does
that mean i have to go take you to get
ice cream
yes it's a national law i got you kids
nice okay
dick's sporting goods the one that i use
to order all sorts of
athletic wear it's teaming up with
instacart to offer
same-day delivery for more than 150
states
that's really smart of them because
during the pandemic they were like oh we
might be slower
i always got it on time but they want to
be even faster and around the holidays
they want to deliver it same day oh
george is one of them i could definitely
okay all right 150 stores actually this
doesn't really matter for
uh dick's sporting goods the car
instacart
this is a big move for instacart i think
because instacart's getting out of the
group they're not getting out but
they're adding to just groceries only
and they're basically saying hey we have
the logistics we can deliver anything
right
so wait till uber eats starts to do this
wait to all of these delivery services
start saying what's the difference
between food
and a non-perishable good because the
non-perishable good is it should
actually be easier to do than food which
is still got to remain hot it can't get
wet it's got all these
things with it so will be interesting
all right this is my favorite story of
the day oh
but on national ice cream day instacart
may actually bring you ice cream
just a pro tip people gonna stop
watching this show because of it
not the kids the kids love the show
and i love everybody here who are you
come on listen okay this is my favorite
story of the day twitter stop looking at
your phone
i'm looking because people are messaging
me twitter
twitter is testing humanization prompts
an effort to reduce toxic supply
so replies
toxic rip lies twitter wants you to
remember that there are
actual people on the other side of your
replies so
here's what it's doing it's testing a
new feature dubbed humanization prompts
with the goal of improving
conversational health on the platform
so when you go to reply something mean
it will tell you the things that you
have in common with the person that
you're replying to
so you and maria both follow the topic
soccer dogs and rap
i'm not sure that will make me like
maria more but it may
humanize her a little bit more what do
you think about this i think it's an
interesting
experiment and let's see what the data
says maybe it works maybe it doesn't
this is one of those things where like
having an opinion is actually
a sign of lack of intelligence because
the interest wait wait having an opinion
is a sign of lack of intelligence in
this scenario because
it's impossible to know whether it works
or not and you can have an opinion
but it's just like if you just operate
on your opinion
then you ignore the data so like okay
cool interesting idea run a test let's
see what the data says if the data says
that this makes people be nicer to each
other and you're optimizing for that
goal
roll it out although i will say there is
also a chance
that it actually makes it worse because
suddenly you're going to have
more information about that person
you're about to attack
and then you're gonna be like oh you
know what maria you like
dogs yeah but you both like dogs because
that's uncomfortable who knows
so are you gonna be like oh you're a dog
lover and they're like sorry
yeah there's ways okay if you really
want to insult somebody you'll insult
somebody well i haven't but
i have the best most sweetest most
friendliest twitter
page on the planet you can attest to
that i i have insults
okay caribbean
oh it's ask lunch money time okay
hashtag ask lm in the comments to ask us
a question what do you want to say
yo dad so fat
no it's a oh my god yo dad's so fat he
don't even fit in the door
that was the worst joke i've ever heard
caribbean queen asks
is it too late to get in or should i
wait for a dip
i'm guessing this is around bitcoin
dollar cost average yep just over time
just keep dollar cost averaging if you
don't know what dollar cost averaging is
google it
it means put in buy a little bit um
periodic periodically at every price
because it averages luis torres
asks hey pomp i took a look at your
linkedin profile and i would like to
understand how you went from studying
economics and sociology to working on
growth for snapchat
and facebook then in finance can you
explain your career path
i just did whatever made me happy
okay can you explain it a little bit
more yeah i'm asked a little bit dude i
went to bucknell
i studied school wow
i went i went to school he studied
school i i i struggled a little bit in
the beginning
uh i've never told anybody this but uh
i had a uh issue the first semester
is this your reading comprehension issue
yeah i had a 1.2 gpa
the first semester 1.2 gpa guys you have
to try to have a gpa
no no i'm sorry 2.0 oh yeah yeah excuse
me let me rewind you have to have a 1.8
to be able to play football and i got a
1.8 that's what it was a 1.8
yeah give me let me get my credit that's
a 50 increase from 1.2 to 1.8 um
but i had a 1.8 and uh
the coach called me into the office and
he said
son son what did you go into the 1940s
to school
he goes he basically was like what are
you doing and i was like
i'm having fun and he was like what like
you can't like what is this is he like
1.8 what are you doing
and uh he asked me if i where i studied
and i used to tell him well you know and
he was like do you go to the library
and then i had to admit to him i didn't
even know where the library was
like it was bad uh and so they put me
along with a couple of my teammates if
any of them are watching they'll
remember this
there's about eight of us every tuesday
and thursday i think it was or every day
i can't remember
they put us in a reading comprehension
course like we were like we're not
idiots
it's like literally the course on like
how to read faster and how to comprehend
and it just turned into a [ __ ] show
because we all went in and just screwed
around and
and whatever guys how did i end up here
i got a 3.8
gpa out of 4.0 but every semester after
that i got like a three six or higher
just because i cuz my boy i was just
trying a little bit i was trying to know
the real story here i won't share it but
okay and then i was just trying i was
just being smart you explained
so then i went from there uh i had
already signed up for the military
uh i got deployed when i was a junior in
college went to
iraq for a year came back finished
school finished playing football
then uh built and sold two uh small
software companies
in north carolina north carolina then
went to facebook ran some product and
growth teams went to snapchat for a
little bit
and then uh started investing full-time
in 2016.
and now i'm on the internet like a
youtuber
because he he i want to be an advocate i
might add that to my profile i might add
that to my linkedin profile just say
current job youtuber
you kids at home who have ice cream
today you can do it too
can i just say can i just say that if
somebody had told me
in college hey you're smart
you do your homework you go to class
you're a good
student they i would end up with
somebody who in remedial english with a
1.8
gpa i think what have i done
kids what has gone on kids where did i
go
wrong follow your passions
youtube is your friend it's the best
teacher you're all about and do your
homework
after you eat the ice cream the homework
thing just listen to your pan if your
parents tell you to do something just do
that but you know
oh my god okay it's time to go listen
that's it that was the only question
yeah no we have two questions
national ice cream day kids make sure
that your parents get you ice cream if
they don't get you ice cream
tell them they're mean and that pop's
not their friend
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6 percent is pretty
compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends